hey mr wonderful here i want to talk  about environmental issues and  sustainability  you're starting to see a lot of it in  the shark tank why is that is it a  marketing scam  is it companies trying to look good and  feel good or is it actually something  consumers are demanding from their  products and that is actually what's  occurring it's the latter  if you are not with a mission of  sustainability  consumers do not want to buy your  product anymore and it's reflected  on the shark tank we're always three  years ahead of everybody else here  we see it coming first and  sustainability  is absolutely number one for consumers  today